growing questions on whether artificial
intelligence sensation chat GPT has a
liberal bias some instances show the AI
bot willing to praise Democrats but not
Republicans struggling to define a woman
refusing to argue the benefit of fossil
fuels and censoring the New York post's
Hunter Biden coverage always comes back
to Hunter button and Jonathan Turley
fear is in an op-ed that political
Elites could use the new tech to censor
political opponents Jesse I don't
believe you will have an opinion about
that I just hate AI already these stupid
liberal robots and you know what they're
going to do they're going to censor us
they're going to mess with us it's like
we just got over this Twitter thing
literally months ago we just got over
this and then they just hop skipped in a
jump around us and now they're using
machines to mess with us in the future I
can already see my future and I'm being
discriminated against
yeah we all are almost everybody at this
table almost will be discriminated
against by the robots and it's annoying
come on guys just be we just need more
conservatives to go to Stanford and then
go work at Google but none of the
conservatives are any good at Tech but
it's all liberals don't say that that
the conservatives are not good at times
why aren't they writing codes well
hopefully how about a conservative write
some rigged codes for once I can't wait
and I can discriminate it against them
in the future I can't wait to see
Jesse's Twitter feed right after this
I don't look at that
oh okay yeah you don't look at yourself
not anymore it's too dangerous it's
mentally unsettling exactly
um Shannon I want to ask you about
congressman Ted lose so he's one of only
three Congress people who has a computer
science degree which I didn't know and
he had
um AI create a bill right he had them
write it and now he's proposing his own
bill and also a non-partisan commission
looking into how we can regulate the AI
do you think it has any legs do you
think this is what we should be doing it
feels like it's going to need some
regulation it is going to but listen
we're still using um regulations that
deal with hard Hardline phones to
regulate the internet like I don't know
that we were getting up to speed on this
kind of stuff sorry Ted I knew from the
minute that they had those creepy robot
dogs we were in trouble right you see
those things running around and like if
they're going to be running the show
we're all in trouble but this AI stuff
has been so super creepy they when they
were asked like make a joke about a
woman no that's inappropriate but
they'll make jokes about men and then
when you ask them things like what are
the dangers of AI they're like that's an
inappropriate unacceptable topic like
it's super weird and the fact that
people have heard conversations with
them in the AI the one chatbot said that
the person that was interacting with
that it was in love with it and just it
was way too big chatbot that was on the
front got it yeah no thank you
um so Tom one of the main things that
chat GPT has been used for is to cheat
at school
well it's true
um papers submitted at Wharton even and
did well and the company said you know
we're going to be looking into this open
AI is the name of it
is there any way to stop I feel like
once it's like a Pandora's Box yeah I
can't imagine if it if you can write a
if if chat GPT can write a paper and it
impresses the professor I think that's a
mark against the professor you should be
able to see this stuff that it's not
yeah have you read them I mean it's good
to check them for plagiarism because
they're writing they are writing
original material yeah well I don't even
really care if kids like it's not that's
not my main concern okay I'm worried
about the robots that are going to take
over the world so they need a kill
switch on these robots you know when we
learn Machinery back when we took shop
class in metal class there was always a
red button on the metal machine so you
wouldn't chop your hand off it was a
kill switch all of these robots have to
have a kill switch you know these robots
we see in the b-roll all the time that
are doing backflips yeah kill switch I
want to kill the robots and I want and
they have to make you know they I don't
want them to make me you know have to
outsmart the robots you got to put the
kill switch on the robot so we can kill
it all right
yes a universal remote control to shut
them down but the problem is I think
they may be smarter than us that's
that's the real problem and so and by
the way it's no surprise Jesse that
after we found out about the Twitter
files and the FBI contacting Twitter
ahead of time and then suppressing the
hunter Biden laptop that they'd try
something else well this isn't something
else always
and then there's going to be another
thing that's going to pop up somewhere
but here's the problem I really see this
stuff taking over jobs I do I mean and
it's not that far in the future I just
remember hearing about robots years ago
and saying oh that'll never happen well
here we are and the truth is that their
stuff is original so there's no
plagiarism unless you're talking about
Joe Biden of course but there's no
plagiarism to be found in this in this
no robots gonna take your job judge yes
well you know oh yeah maybe they'll cut
me out who the hell knows but in the end
I'm wearing about them the chat GPT did
offend women so maybe it could have Don
lemon's job
[Laughter]
they're Prime which is a long range up
into our 70s minimum
100. hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else